buen día un gusto estar con ustedes
en realidad no parece que asistimos a
una inusual tensión en la región entre
un gobierno de derecha y la
administración estadounidense de hecho
hernández de ser el principal aliado de
los eeuu en el triángulo norte
ha evolucionado a ser un aliado incómodo
en los últimos meses de la
administración trump y prácticamente ser
considerado como un paria en la actual
administración
de baile
en realidad pues
entonces podemos decir de que la
relación entre la política y el
narcotráfico con honduras es de larga
data pero que en los últimos diez años
se ha construido una relación especial
en la cual prácticamente la
institucionalidad del país ha pasado a
ser captada por lo que se consideran
redes de corrupción redes criminales
donde han participado funcionarios
públicos y por críticos dentro de ellos
incluso alto jefe de la policía y
barones de la droga que precisamente son
los que están en este momento esperando
juicios en la corte de instituciones y
ahora qué impacto tienen estas
acusaciones en la política interna de
honduras un país que ha estado sumido en
la corrupción durante mucho tiempo
bueno en esto hay que considerar de que
honduras no es una democracia ni
siquiera podemos decir que una
democracia de baja densidad como se
califica a una buena parte de los países
de américa latina sino que realmente con
la autocracia electoral en la cual
prácticamente toda la institucionalidad
y todos los poderes del prestado ha
pasado a ser controlada por el señor
hernández
ha sido un proceso de construcción en
estos últimos ocho años
el gobierno
y sentido pues decirte que en ese
momento ni siquiera con una ley
electoral de lo que ha estado en la mesa
ha sido ejecutado en la nueva reforma
electoral no ha sido posible de ahí que
la crisis que tenemos en este momento a
ese nivel con las elecciones primarias
es una expresión de ello luego también
hay que reconocer que hernández a lo
largo de estos ocho años y producto una
política clientelista centrada en
poblaciones pobres urbana y rural pues
posee una base social que no es
despreciable pero también hay que
reconocer de que existe una amplia
oposición
de diferentes sectores en el país hablan
de sí pero desafortunadamente también
existe una oposición política muy
fragmentada y va a depender mucho y en
eso ya se están dando algunos caminos de
una articulación de una alianza
electoral para poder que esto tenga un
impacto en la política interna